bonjour et bienvenue pour ce nouveau 7,8
week-end l'émission dédiée à vous sorti
et vos loisirs
au sommaire aujourd'hui nous allons
consacrer une large page au sport
féminin et à la journée de la femme
puisqu'à cette occasion de nombreuses
communes et institutions proposent des
animations et notamment le district de
football des yvelines il sera à huy en
cours samedi pour montrer que le
football n'est pas qu'un sport
deux garçons petits jeux et quiz sont au
programme jusqu'au 13 mars l'estaminet
accueille une exposition autour des
himbas peuple semi-nomade de namibie
pour y découvrir leurs traditions et
leur culture et le vélodrome nationale
sera mardi 8 mars le théâtre d'une
soirée spéciale fis baptêmes de piste
gala des championnes et channing sont
proposés aux amatrices et un ouvrage est
aussi consacrée au vélodrome nationale
et le sport se conjugue donc aussi au
féminin ça peut paraître un cliché de le
dire comme ça mais à l'occasion de la
journée de la femme
de nombreuses institutions et communes
ont souhaité mettre l'accent sur le
sport féminin et pour avec notre
première invitée nous allons parler de
football fa demain jeudi
vous êtes la présidente de la commission
féminine du district de football des
yvelines où genre alors le district
multiplient les actions pour faire
connaître le football féminin et vous
serez présente à guyancourt je le disais
tout à l'heure
qu'est ce qu'on va pouvoir voir ce
week-end donc ce week-end vous allez
avoir en fait une animation au coeur des
villes
c'est le genre d'animation qu'on a
commencé à mettre en place depuis pas
très longtemps
ça va se
situé au niveau de la place du marché
c'est en fait on va pouvoir mettre en
place un petit terrain synthétique qui
va être délimité des barrières autour
des petites cages de but et pique sur un
ballon et
les jeunes filles voilà qui seront
présentes qui tourneront autour avec mes
collègues nous allons pouvoir voilà leur
parlais justement du foot féminin pour
ceux qui ne connaissent pas encore même
si c'est justement voilà si c'est en
bonne voie
on appuie sur football féminin il ya une
différence par rapport au football
masculin ou non celle des mêmes règles
si les mêmes règles c'est vrai qu'après
que voilà c'est pas pareil le jeu
masculin et un peu plus brute les filles
sont nettement plus techniques sont
nettement plus gracieuse entre 0,6 et
il y a nettement plus de bouche quand
même en plus le football féminin
commence à émerger on a une équipe de
france on a le psg noël qui font des
belles gueules carrière des bons
résultats
exactement en plus on a la chance sur le
niveau de notes de notre département
d'avoir justement et que leurs
promoteurs comme parle comme le paris
saint germain et on a d'autres clubs
aussi et là c'est en train de prendre
une bonne expansion faut bien savoir que
cette année nous avons eu une
augmentation d'un peu plus de 23%
bientôt on aura la coupe du monde
des filles en 2019 qu'on va accueillir
en france on a vraiment une grande
chance nous sommes en train justement de
préparer tout ça et samedi vous allez
donc faire découvrir le photo jeune
fille mais est-ce qu'il faut aussi
parfois à rassurer les parents combattre
certains clichés
bien sûr bien sûr avec mes collègues on
sera là justement pour leur en parler un
petit peu faut savoir qu'il ya nettement
plus de clubs féminins au niveau du
département
on a eu vraiment une énorme évolution et
on est là justement pour leur parler un
petit peu de tous les cas qui auraient
donc à proximité de leur domicile
il ya de quoi faire on a raison il ya
deux hommes va faire il ya vraiment de
quoi faire
vers l'âge pour commencer le football on
les accueille des cinq ans après
jusqu'en la distance il ya et pour ce
week-end il faut s'inscrire où les gens
peuvent pas d'une région viennent comme
ça justement je les invite vraiment tout
ça tout ça à venir sur place nous serons
là toute la matinée jusqu'à 12h30 et
voilà je les invite vraiment à avenir à
venir nous voir et nous et nous et
notamment nous allons avoir une autre
une grosse manifestation le samedi 12
mars
vu que le 8 mars la journée de la femme
tombe en semaine le samedi 12 de 2o mars
avec avec la cohésion sociale nous
allons mettre en place justement une
une matinée où il va y avoir des filles
au foot des u11 enfin un petit peu tous
les âges jusqu'à jusqu'à 15 ans et faire
de leur temps aux panels et l'évolution
qu'ils jouaient des morts et il y aura
même justement des filles non licenciés
qui sont et qui sont aussi dans quelle
donc invités à venir à cette
manifestation la histoire d'être
ensemble de jouer convivialité assurée
sur en plus de sa j'invite aussi toutes
les mamans voilà qui ont même enfin qui
n'en pâtit aussi qui joue qui joue qui
jouent au foot mais là qui en iran fils
aux autres je les invite à venir lors de
cette journée justement le samedi 12
mars ce sera vraiment une matinée
spécialement femmes
merci ça ne m'a jamais venu nous parler
avant le 12 mars il ya donc le samedi 5
mars est accueilli en cours rendez vous
sur la place du marché du pont du
quartier du pont du rotois guillon court
ça se passe donc le 5 mars de 10h à 12h
et je vous en parlais la semaine
dernière à magny les hameaux il y a
aussi une programmation autour de la
journée de la femme puisque durant deux
semaines
la commune met à l'honneur les peuples
nomades et l'estaminet accueille une
exposition sur les unes bas peuple de
namibie reportage
le rouge c'est celui de locre dont ce
peuple sans lui les himbas peuple
semi-nomade de la libye sont à l'honneur
de la semaine de la femme mme annick
oise chez les himbas c'est une société
matriarcale et l'héritage se transmet
par les femmes
c'est un peuple aussi qui lutte vraiment
pour sa survie
et enfin pour sa survie au sens être nos
logiques du terme c'est-à-dire
culturellement ils sont confrontés avec
la société moderne
le développement du tourisme en libye et
s'est gardé au maximum
sa structure familiale plongée au coeur
des traditions des coutumes de ce peuple
cette exposition présentée pour la
première fois en 2008 est à l'initiative
d'une femme une française
solenn bardet ethnologue et géographe
elle avait 18 ans elle est partie seule
en afrique elle y est restée deux ans
auprès de du peuple himba elle a même
été adoptée donc par par khadidja une
femme qui va devenir plus tard chefs de
tribus et depuis c'est elle qui est le
porte parole au niveau occidental est
venue de ce peuple qui risque d'être en
voie de disparition
l'exposition est à découvrir au café de
l'estaminet jusqu'au dimanche 13 mars
une visite guidée est organisée le 9
mars prochain
de quoi plonger un peu plus en terre
inconnue on continue sur notre
thématique la journée de la femme et
cette fois on prend la direction du
vélodrome national de saint quentin en
yvelines
il propose le mardi 8 mars une soirée
entre filles et pour en parler nous
aurons jouent en plateau bruno l'équipe
bonjour bonjour vous êtes en charge de
la formation à la fédération française
de cyclisme et booth golstein qui est
responsable communication du vélodrome
bonjour à tous les deux oui et notre
troisième invité c'est thomas bauer qui
est auteur d'un ouvrage sur le vélodrome
et on en parlera tout à l'heure alors je
me tende avant leur vol et qui une
journée consacrée au cyclisme féminin
pourquoi la ffc a voulu on dresse aussi
un un rapport avec la journée
internationale de la femme il faut
savoir que la fédération française de
cyclisme reçoit du ministère des sports
une délégation de pouvoir et donc dans
cette délégation de pouvoir elle a des
missions assurées qui concerne bien
évidemment le haut niveau qui est le
coeur de métier de notre fédération
mais qui concerne aussi la promotion des
disciplines auprès de tout public
or il s'avère qu'à la fédération on a un
taux de licencier féminin qui est très
faible qui à peu près de 10%
c'est en moyenne 30% pour toutes les
autres fédérations et on manque
cruellement de fin mai donc on voulait
par l'intermédiaire de cette journée
organiser une approche du cyclisme qui
soit peut-être décalé par rapport au
haut niveau
qu'est ce qui fait que les familles pour
moi c'est clair je pense que c'est une
représentation c'est à dire que pour
tout le monde le cyclisme le cyclisme à
la fédération le cyclisme au vélodrome
c'est vraiment une approche du haut
niveau est historiquement et bien c'est
vrai que les femmes ont eu du mal à
s'imposer
elles n'ont pas été aidés par les les
hommes aussi un puisqu'il ya eu beaucoup
de barrages et aujourd'hui on se
retrouve dans une situation où il ya
très peu de femmes pratiquante mais
aussi dirigeante et ce jour là il n'y
aura pas que le sport de haut niveau
vous l'avez dit c'est pour tout le monde
sait ce qu'ils voudraient aussi de
découvrir le cyclisme
ouais c'est ça c'est à dire que on a
imaginé cette journée comme une
découverte comme une action auprès de
toutes les femmes
et donc c'est une journée où on va faire
du baptême c'est à dire qu'on va initier
tout le monde essentiellement les femmes
à la pratique du cyclisme
on aura des exposants on aura des
ateliers au centre on aura même un
atelier aussi avec des draisienne pour
acquérir les enfants parce que ça peut
être un frein aussi à la pratique
féminine et l'idée c'est de faire
pratiquer au niveau local c'est à dire
sur saint quentin sur la communauté de
communes les les femmes du de la commune
je tourne vers vous grosse bataille
puisque c'est au vélodrome nationale où
s'entraîne l'équipe de france une
animation comme ça mettre en avant les
faits c'est aussi important pour la
structure tout à fait très importante
déjà pour accompagner notre partenaire
la fédération française de cyclisme dont
nous sommes voisins
et puis ensuite parce que le concept
nous a semblé tout à fait légitime et
est opportun pour mettre en place des
produits pérenne par la suite parce que
c'est un c'est un levier événementielle
qui va nous permettre de voir justement
d'installer la pratique au sein du
cercle féminin parce que il ya le disait
l'équipe de france qu'il s'entraîne mais
les amateurs des clubs du coin viennent
aussi chez vous il n'y a pas beaucoup de
filles vous le sentait aussi
ah oui oui ça s'étend
c'est un état de fait on enregistre un
peu plus de 400 abonnés sur la piste et
on n'a que quelques femmes à droite
c'est même en dessous de la dizaine de
femmes parmi ses abonnés dont là c'est
une opportunité de développer ce fait
cible et d'actionner ce levier que
symbolise la soirée entre filles autour
du cyclisme mais packers une soirée
entre filles
donc il ya des massages c'est ça on a
plusieurs ateliers notamment comme vous
le stipuler des massages de la mise en
beauté on a un atelier de deux
reviennent également
et puis on finalise tout cela par une
soirée où tout le monde est convié oui
bah en fait tous les créneaux sont
complets pour vous dire donc on avait
mis en place si créneau les quatre
chronos se sont blindés en à peine trois
heures les créneaux pour les baptêmes
parce que tout ce que les autres
animations les gens peuvent venir
exactement pour venir se faire pouponner
c'est une soirée entre copines pour les
baptêmes ou non les crises ce sont des
manques de la fsc clients et encadreront
les
alors des membres de l'afc mais aussi
des membres de vélo police puisque nous
avons des encadrants effectivement
diplômés qui vont réaliser ces baptêmes
et donc sont des baptêmes sous une forme
assez rapides ces trente minutes mais ça
va permettre de découvrir la piste le
vélo est de pouvoir rouler sur cette
piste qui est quand même mythique un
déjà sept cinétique parce qu'en l'espace
d'un an d'un an et demi à la gamme
accueillait les championnats de france
et championnat du monde
la caméra les championnats d'europe
c'est une belle reconnaissance c'est
pour la structure de faire une soirée
comme ça de faire venir les gens dans
cette structure
tout à fait c'est une piste unique au
monde donc
doit l'honorer et mettre en place ce
type de concept événementiel donc
structures nationales journée nationale
et vous fait venir une grande championne
en tant que marraine pauline ferrand
prévôt vraiment pas là vous serez pas
nécessairement très connu du public
pourtant elle a une superbe carrière
pauline c'est une très très grande
championne bon elle est identifiée déjà
depuis un petit moment à la fédération
puisque lll a été double championne du
monde déjà en juniors aujourd'hui elle
n'est plus que double championne du
monde elle a perdu un titre en septembre
celui de route
l'année dernière elle avait les trois
titres sur trois disciplines différentes
la route le vtt et le cyclo cross
donc c'est une jeune femme et c'est une
jeune femme qui peut symboliser
justement ce plan de féminisation et
elle va venir en tant que marraine pour
soutenir cette pratique encore une fois
ouverte à tout public
le pouvoir et pour nos questions et
inquiétudes peut-être de certaines
filles qui pourrait se dire balle faire
du sport fin du cycle et ce n'était pas
très féminin ouais c'est vraiment ça
c'est à dire que c'est montrer que le
cyclisme c'est une une pratique qui est
féminine c'est une pratique qui
correspond aussi à une logique de
société aujourd'hui avec le bien-être la
prise en compte de la santé
c'est donc important qu'elles puissent
venir faire passer sa passion et puis
montrer que tout le monde peut faire du
vélo et à sera pas seul puisqu'il y aura
laurie berton olivia montauban qu'elles
sont aujourd'hui à londres si je me
trompe pas oui c'est ça c'est les
championnats du monde aujourd'hui et
toute la semaine à londres
donc oui on aura des membres de l'équipe
de france piste féminine et qui vont
aussi participer soit sur des interviews
soit sûr
aussi sur des baptêmes et puis on va
essayer de faire rouler tout le monde
aussi ensemble sur sur des épreuves de
démonstration aussi parce que vous allez
leur proposer de s'affronter aussi sur
des épreuves
oui on va essayer de monter un programme
sportif mais l'objectif c'est vraiment
de d'amener tout le monde et de montrer
que le cyclisme sur piste du cyclisme en
général est accessible à toutes les fans
donc accessible à toutes les femmes pour
celles qui seraient intéressés je vous
le rappelle c'est le mardi 8 mars ça
commence à 17 heures et 7 au vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines à
montigny le bretonneux
on continue on reste au vélodrome mais
on change un petit peu on va faire un
petit peu d'histoire aussi parce que la
structure est actuellement est au coeur
d'un ouvrage qui s'appelle vélodrome 50
ans les villes un héritage en partage et
c'est thomas bauer un des auteurs qui
étaient là avec nos hauts plateaux
pourquoi avoir choisi de parler du
vélodrome nationale pourquoi avoir
choisi
c'est ce qu'ils ne rencontrent au départ
c'est une rencontre comme disaient les
surréalistes dans les années 30 il y
avait dans la revue minotaure c'est
qu'elle est la rencontre capitale de
votre vie je crois que c'est ça c'est
avant tout des rencontres entre les
hommes et entre des hommes qui
s'apprécient donc là c'est une rencontre
informelle au cours d'un déjeuner avec
thierry des eaux qui le pdg d'une
société qui s'appelle meridia mais qui
est donc la société qui a participé à la
construction financement et à la mise en
place avec l'agglomération saint quentin
en yvelines de ce vélodrome nationale
bien sûr il y avait au départ la société
bouygues mais c'est donc la soutiennent
meridiam qui a porté une bonne partie du
projet vous parlez du vélodrome mais
vous êtes aussi historien yport donc
vous ne faites pas que la structure en
elle même vous avez complètement raison
donc cette rencontre a permis
effectivement d'échanger avec thierry
des eaux et la société néo diable et moi
en tant qu'historien du sport une
rencontre s'est faite entre la manière
de renouer sur la modernité de ce site
avec l'héritage et l'histoire des
vélodromes et du cyclisme sur piste a
évidemment
les vélodromes était devenu désuet
lamont un peu passé de mode et avait été
déboussolé en tout cas pris de vitesse
par les stades de football et donc le
fait de reconstruire un vélodrome
magnifique merveilleux un site
d'innovation technologique c'était une
manière de renouer avec cet héritage et
notamment cet héritage franciliens parce
que paris et l'île de france ont
toujours eu de grands vélodrome je pense
notamment aux buffalos je pense à la
cipale à vincennes je pense au parc des
princes que vous donnez un stade de foot
est extraordinaire et puis bien
évidemment le vel d'hiv
koné pour un autre pan des stars à moins
forte quand même connu et
malheureusement qui a laissé son nom
dans l'histoire de la cause de la rafle
du vel d'hiv en juillet 1942 mais mais
qui fait un des fleurons finalement du
cyclisme français et des vélodromes je
dirais presque mondiaux puisqu'ils s'ils
couraient notamment la célèbre course
des six jours de paris qui est restée
mémorable et historique
wasquehal stein qu'il est aussi déjà un
livre sur le vélodrome c'est c'était
important pour la structure très
important d'une part pour valoriser le
patrimoine architectural et puis d'autre
part pour mettre en scène volet culturel
de la structure donc évidemment c'est un
ouvrage très précieux pour développer
cette facette du vélodrome aider j'en
suis le premier ravi surtout de
travailler et collaborer avec thomas ce
qui présage aussi des axes de
développement novateurs pour la suite il
y a cinq parties dans l'ouvragé vous
parler de l' architecture puisque ces
gigantesques quand on passe à côté on le
remarque les sportifs bien sûr on en a
parlé de bruno les quais l'équipe de
france s'entraîne on les voit assez
régulièrement mais vous parlez aussi des
coulisses et des acteurs il ya
énormément de monde qui travaille dans
ce dans cette structure
oui tout à fait et c'était l'objectif de
cet ouvrage qui n'était pas simplement
de se focaliser sur les champions parce
que ça c'est un site une évidence pas
non plus sur la piste parce que c'est
une architecture mais aussi surtout ses
pertes tout sept personnes tous ces
personnels qui oeuvrent au quotidien qui
permettent de monter les événements
d'entretenir la
pis liste entretenir les locaux donc les
masseurs les techniciens les ouvriers
les informaticiens les journalistes donc
tous ces gens là effectivement qui
participent à la vie du vélodrome et
donc on voulait faire un clin d'oeil
avec mon co auteur tony froissart je
tiens aussi à souligner puisqu'on l'a
pas évoquée et donc ça a permis
effectivement d'avoir un une vision
relativement large et diverse sur la
vidéo mais il ya aussi les variations on
n'a pas parlé parce que un vélodrome
je vous coupe peut-être est-ce que je
voulais juste venir vous disais il ya
beaucoup non ça s'est vu à l'occasion
des championnats du monde l'an dernier
ça
outre le public qui était présent ça
grouillait de monde ça quand le
vélodrome est rempli c'est des milliers
des milliers de personnes qui
travaillent au tour en terme de public
c'est 5000 personnes par jour les
mondiaux donc au total un peu plus de
5000 personnes et après évidemment en
mode événementiel on est des centaines
de patrons centaine de bénévoles d'une
part et puis ensuite tout le staff
technique donc effectivement ça grouille
de stuff
beaucoup de journalistes et de la
communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin eric qui nous aide aussi
sur le développement de ces événements
dans la structure de l'ouvragé donc il y
avait des cinq parcs si on parlait des
variations un petit mot oui parce que
l'histoire d'hélène drôme c'est aussi
l'histoire d'une polyvalence sportive
puisque enlever l'eau drôme on y
pratique toutes sortes d'activités le
football comme c'était le cas au parc
des princes la boxe le patinage le
cirque
il y avait des meetings politiques y
avait des shows musicaux il y avait des
concerts donc c'est vraiment un lieu de
vie ouvert sur toutes les formes de
manifestation et avant que les stades de
football ne soit construit finalement
c'était le lieu de rassemblement
populaire le vélodrome et c'est pour ça
que le vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines est à nouveau
une occasion de renouer avec ce voile à
cette histoire et de la faire vivre et
pour des primes à lille de la plus belle
tradition ils perpétuent la tradition
exactement sur la composition du de
l'ouvragé vous fait la part belle aux
photos c'est oui c'était l'objectif de
cet ouvrage c'est de ne pas faire un
ouvrage trop documentaire mais plus tôt
ouvrage de photographies un peu de la
manière un peu esthétique un livre d'art
finalement toutes proportions gardées
pour faire ressentir des émotions au
lecteur et lui permettent de vivre
vraiment de l'émotion en consultant ses
photos et ses pages qui sont en fait un
dialogue perpétuelle permanent entre
l'histoire et la modernité entre le
passé et aujourd'hui donc c'est vraiment
l'objectif de de ce livre qui est une
forme de web de dialogue et il est
préfacé par un immense champion
il est préfacé par florian rousseau
effectivement que j'ai eu il y a
plusieurs années comme collègue à
l'insep
florian rousseau qui est évidemment un
immense champion de la piste qui a été
triple champion olympique et qui était
également pendant de nombreuses années
l'entraîneur national de l'équipe de
france dans les pieds de cyclisme sur
piste
voilà il nous a fait l'honneur
effectivement d'accepter cette cette
préface puisqu'on l'avait sollicité car
c'est un joueur nous avoir fait des
cloîtres ouvrage
merci à tous les trois des devenu en
plateau peut-être remercier les éditions
donc aussi qui donc voila vous l'avez vu
moi ça refait le vélodrome saint-quentin
levin l'héritage en partage ton amour
alors qu'était la tenue froid ça aux
éditions on change maintenant de sujets
ce que comme chaque semaine les
libraires du pavé du canal vous propose
une idée lecture cette semaine le coup
de coeur de laurent gara c'est je suis
chars liberté d' arthur ténor et nous le
présente vous présente je suis chars
liberté d' arthur ténor qu'un livre
jeunesse dédié aux enfants d'à peu près
douze enfants entre 10 et 12 ans et
c'est donc un livre qui est vraiment qui
suit l'actualité qui prend toutes les
thématiques qu'on a nous actuellement là
au niveau de la société qui sont la
liberté d'expression et la laïcité donc
c'est une histoire de collégiens qui
sont en classe de 3e qui souhaitent
monter un petit fanzine à 3 et donc
c'est toutes les embûches et août tous
les soucis qu'ils vont rencontrer pour
monter ce journal donc ils vont réussir
finalement a publié avec la lie avec
l'accord du proviseur et après par
contre ça va être tout les réactions en
chaîne qui vont avoir qui vont avoir
finalement en face d'eux par rapport à
ce que ce soit les personnes de leur
classe où finalement le corps enseignant
enfin tout ce que finalement on tout les
thèmes toutes les thématiques de société
qui n'ont qui ont qui ont lieu
actuellement interdit de ce livre c'est
qu'on y voit vraiment toutes les
thématiques donc il ya cette histoire de
nous mettre le curseur sur la liberté
individuelle
jusqu'à où on peut donner les
informations et jusqu'à où on peut être
finalement impartiale vis-à-vis de
l'information
il ya aussi ça traite aussi de la
religion donc qu'est ce que la laïcité
est ce que nous on peut accepter que
l'autre soit différent ou pas et donc
c'est vraiment toutes ces thématiques
qui seront abordées d'un point de vue
finalement de collégiens mais qui
peuvent aussi ça convient tout le monde
finalement ce livre que ce soit les
enfants qui vont avoir une première
lecture comme ça mais les parents aussi
qui vont découvrir pas mal de choses à
travers ce livre et si c'est dans les
salles obscures que vous souhaitez vous
rendre luc beaucourt le directeur du
ciné 7 d'elancourt vous présente ses
coups de coeur mon coup de coeur cette
semaine par le coup de coeur du ciné
cette semaine c'est spotlight récemment
oscarisée sa date de dimanche dernier un
oscar très mérité un très très bon film
d' enquête un don c'est un petit peu un
film dans la veine des hommes du
président pour ceux qui l'ont vu avec
robert redford et dustin hoffman ya
quelques années un film d' enquête donc
inspiré d'une histoire vraie ça retrace
en fait une équipe de journalistes sort
d'une équipe de journalistes qui va
aller fouiller dans un scandale de
pédophilie dans l'église américaine
voilà donc c'est très très bien
c'est avec michael norton
rachel mcadams un mark ruffalo et c'est
vraiment un film à voir qu'ils ont tous
les droits numériques sont et ce carton
qu'on l'entend aussi 17 en vf cette
semaine un petit mot aussi n'oubliez pas
de venir voir le dernier film des frères
coen avaient césar c'est toujours un
plaisir de cinéma un régal avec entre
autres george clooney josh brolin qui a
été d'ailleurs sauvé au niveau de sa
carrière par les frères coen avec que no
country for old men pour ceux qui l'ont
vue de signer cette d'elancourt vous
propose aussi le dimanche 6 mars à 10
heures 30 une projection pour les
enfants dans ma petite planète verte des
personnages courageux et malins font
preuve d'inventivité surtout protège la
planète ce sont plusieurs courts
métrages pour sensibiliser à
l'environnement on regarde un extrait
et on termine ce site week-end avec une
compétition sportive jusqu'à dimanche
vous pourrez assister à une compétition
de black ball au centre sportif des
pyramides
c'est un voisins le bretonneux on écoute
alain vous fait l'organisateur il nous
explique ce qu'est le black ball le
black ball en fait c'est plus connus où
s'étaient connus sous l'appellation de
poule
donc c'est des petits billard à poches
avec six trous et avec des beats de
couleurs rouge et jaune et donc le jeu
consiste
c'est une confrontation entre deux
joueurs après ce qu'on appelle la casse
disperser les billes sur le billard le
un joueur un moment donné entre une
couleur donnée et il doit le premier
vide et sa couleur et en terminer par ce
qu'on appelle la 8 bits blanche
le site week-end est terminée je vous
remercie de nous avoir suivis et je vous
souhaite une excellente fin de semaine